the anime community has been plagued by
a question over the past week
over a character who's getting hate on
levels we haven't seen since rachel from
tower of god
last summer which was honestly a sight
to see
the question being of course should we
hate gabby
the girl who ignored falco's advice and
the facts in front of her
and decided to kill sasha the best of
the bestest of girls
most people that i've seen at least
through my scopes on tick tock and
twitter believe that
oh yeah we [ __ ] hate gabby which is
completely fair
and to answer the question posed in the
title of the video
yeah we should definitely hate gabby but
yes there is always a but we must also
accept her
and understand what she's done and why
she's done it yeah they had us the first
half i'm not gonna lie
now look before you go and dislike the
video because i'm coming to
the defense of gabby hear me out isayama
has made one of the biggest points in
attack on titan to be the ambiguity of
what evil is
he wants us to question who is doing the
right thing if anyone even is
we aren't meant to support aaron
wholeheartedly as he commits mass
genocide
or be absolutely against gabby for
retaliating when her home was destroyed
isayama saved sasha from dying in season
2 for a number of reasons
and it's not coincidence that he decided
to let her die at this specific point in
the story and chose gabby to be the one
to do it
i think gabby is written to be hated but
accepted despite that
because not only have we seen what she's
doing the hatred she's feeling before
in season 1 erin but also because she is
just another
demonstration of the show's theme that
history can
and will repeat itself through violence
she's another piece of the puzzle that
works to show the beauty of attack on
titan and the moral questioning it
creates
gabby slander is honestly hilarious and
this scene where like a bunch of grown
dudes are just beating the crap
out of her is so funny to me i don't
know if that's messed up or not but
it's just to reassure you all that i do
also hate gaby
we just have to understand her purpose
in the story before rushing to call her
like the worst person ever
gabby has done something wrong of course
she has she killed someone pretty much
uninvolved in her reason for revenge
even but everyone has made mistakes
done something wrong the whole purpose
of attack on titan now is to emphasize
the blurred line between who's good and
not
on top of that gabby is meant to mirror
aaron
i said this in my recent video about
aaron becoming the villain and i just
want to make it even more clear here
gabby is filled with hatred just as
aaron was when he was younger
for both of them this stems from an
enemy titan attacking their home and
killing tons of people
including some of those close to them
she has purposely written this way to
demonstrate the cycles of violence we
see in attack on titan
that history will never change unless
something drastic
like what aaron plans to do is done
think about this if the story began at
season four you had no knowledge of
everything that's happened so far before
that you were just thrown in at marley
wouldn't gabby be the protagonist right
now
the potential recruit for becoming the
titan shifter who can defeat the devils
of the island
wouldn't that be heroic but of course i
acknowledge that there are definitely
differences in the context of both
characters backstories
gabby is fully aware of the fact that
marley did this first to the islanders
a lot of people claiming she deserves
all the hate bring up that she ignored
this
when falco told her about it but let me
play the devil's advocate here look at
it this way
aaron is currently well aware of the
history between marlins and aldians
that knowledge has not stopped him from
killing dozens if not hundreds of
innocent marlians and aldians within
marley
who have never personally done anything
to hurt the islanders
if aaron is well aware of the whole
historical context between the two
nations but
ignores it to continue his plan why
should we expect gabby to stop either
it's isaiah's way of emphasizing that
cycle of violence
that it doesn't matter who started the
fight because people are driven by
emotions as well
instead of just always common sense
whoever first attacked paradise island
has nothing to do with gabby in her head
and before you dispute that i mean are
you blaming the people of paradise for
what
eldians did centuries before them the
blood-filled history of eldians
subjugating marlene are you attributing
part of that blame to aaron to armin the
islanders
at all no of course not because they
didn't do it directly and neither did
gabby
we can't blame someone for the crimes of
their ancestors
her purpose in the broader scope of
things is to tear down this double
standard for us
as the audience we have a predisposed
bias to support the islanders to support
the survey core and
aaron but we can't expect gabby to have
some moral compass just because she
knows that the marlins may have started
this fight
she's just a person with feelings and
she's gonna act on them and take revenge
so i guess i'm not saying that gabby is
good and has done nothing wrong
but that we just have to look at it
through a more open-minded lens
something that season 4 is trying to do
a lot
the final season is filled with
characters who ride the line between
good and evil
the typers did the declaration of war to
ensure that the aldians within marley
the titan shifters
still had a use to the marlians zeke
needed the tibers because they had a
reputation and the ability to save
eldians who
with the advance of technology that
overwhelmed even titans in the first
episode
were on the verge of becoming useless to
the marlins once eldians became useless
people who are essentially slaves they
probably would have been killed by the
marlins or thrown out
i mean just look at how they're treated
now if they had no use then
they'd be worth absolutely nothing
but by declaring war the tibers are not
only betraying the peace desired by the
king within the walls who long ago
colluded with them
but they are making out a minority of
their own race who they want to protect
into the villains to do so reiner long
ago
invaded the walls was responsible for
tons of deaths betrayed the survey corps
but he's now written with ptsd and guilt
over everything that happens
i mean can you hate him right now aaron
i mean we know how aaron is good and
evil now just watch the season
what i'm trying to say is that everyone
has faults at this point everyone is
bearing the burden
of having to hurt someone else a
necessary evil to get what they want
and that's the beauty of attack on titan
that's why i love this series so much
the fact that gabby had to kill sasha at
this point is sad
but i mean that's what isayama wanted he
needed the most innocent lovable
character in the show to die
not only to show that there are always
stakes in war
the possibility that even with the best
plan there will be sacrifice
but also to prove that nobody's all that
great anymore
you know as a manga reader i still hate
gabby i still can't really forgive her
for what she's done
but i don't think anyone needs or
deserves forgiveness in the story
reiner will always be a traitor zeke
will always be that one
[ __ ] who levi needs to kill like
seriously can someone please kill this
dude
like i know he's like on their side now
or whatever but please levi just like
just take him out man i'm tired of
seeing that bearded face look at me
straight in the eyes after killing the
survey core
and gabby will always be sasha's killer
that is the pain we have to live with as
we watch or
read attack on titan the loss we have to
accept when realizing that no one is
wholly justified or
unjustified but that's just the way of
the world
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses